this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 35.
Echo Charles sitting here with me and we
missed a week of underground apologies
uh and then
I got reminded we we got reminded why we
have the underground why we have Jocko
underground.com the reason is because we
realized a while ago that we don't
control any of the platforms that we
put our podcast out on top of that we
don't control the platforms that we
interact with people on social media we
don't control those platforms we don't
control YouTube We Don't control the
algorithms we don't control any of the
podcast feeds that are out there so
that's not a good situation to be in
where you have no control over your own
destiny
where you have to bow to
control of a greater entity that you
have no control over so we started this
what you're listening to right now Jocko
on the ground Jocko underground.com we
started it we we actually started it we
had we did a podcast about the book
1984. in light of the of the freedom of
speech being in impinged upon
I actually called you I was driving home
and said bro we need to we need to come
up with a contingency plan in case
something happens so we created this
and and
we created as a contingency right
and really quite frankly there had been
very limited indicators that we would
have to utilize the contingency well for
us personally we did see other people
get impacted friends
Associates where all of a sudden they'd
get banned they'd get kicked off they'd
get demonetized all these problems
well guess what just happened
I ended up getting Shadow banned on
social media
and I got on on
a specific social media platform I got
band or Shadow band they called it which
is a weird thing because I didn't really
know and I don't I I kind of can look
back now and people have explained to me
and I've looked at some uh what is it
analytics and seen that it was actually
for a longer period of time than I
initially thought but someone someone
finally a couple people would mentioned
it in comments bro you're sad or Shadow
band Your Shadow band and I think well
you know okay whatever it's sort of like
a uh I appreciate people saying I wasn't
blowing them off but I didn't hey you
how are you seeing this you're seeing it
so you're writing your Shadow band how I
didn't pay much attention to it I should
have I should have listened
um but then I finally started getting a
couple people sending me videos of them
searching for
for my name or scrolling through their
timeline and I'm not in it and they
follow me
and or typing my name into the search
and it doesn't show up unless you
literally put at Jocko willink right
anything else you would Jocko like I'm
not in there that's called The Shadow
band
and what's strange about this is look
you all listen to me you know what I
talk about I don't talk I don't
usually talk in any hyper political way
I'd sometimes do that on interviews
but I re but as far as social I'll do it
on podcasts a little bit but as far as
social media goes I rarely will post
something that's you know some political
statement for a few reasons number one I
think that social media is a bad place
to discuss politics
and if I want to discuss something
political I want to have a as much time
as I want to discuss it
and so that's why I'll usually do it on
a podcast
but I don't I I'm not posting anything
offensive I really don't post a lot of
stuff that's like oh hyper controversial
now if I do it's
when I do Post
things that are that to express my
political beliefs
normally well what I do is I do it in a
way where it's an indirect message the
message is if you understand what I'm
saying the message is very clear
if you're looking for someone to ban you
might not quite it might not hit your
algorithm
well why do I do that well there's a
couple reasons why I do that number one
because I want people to listen to what
I'm saying I want them to be able to
listen what I'm saying and number two if
you're on the other side of my political
beliefs
and you hear me directly attack what you
believe you probably aren't going to
listen anything else I said so I'd
rather take an indirect approach like I
do with most things because the indirect
approach proven is a more effective way
to communicate and to move forward
so
it kind of surprised me when I got
Shadow banned so why did I get Shadow
banned I'm not a hundred percent sure
but here are my best guesses and there
are two things that stand out
that I've done over the past couple
months that I think think could have
made me a Target and like I said I'm not
exactly sure when I got Shadow banned
but it could have been for a pretty long
stretch because I don't pay a ton of
attention to that kind of thing I don't
I don't pay attention to very close
attention to oh this thing got this many
likes or this many views or this many
followers I don't I don't pay a lot of
attention to that so when I went back
and did a retro look at it I realized oh
this has been going on for a while yeah
this has been going on for a while
so why did it happen here's the my two
best guesses
the first
was I made that video of If I Was
President this is what I would have said
oh yeah so
that speech that I made was me saying
hey if I was President Biden and we were
in the situation in Afghanistan and we
were had people Americans killed we had
billions of dollars of equipment left
behind we had civilians
Left Behind American citizens Left
Behind American Allies left behind an
unmitigated disaster
if that would have happened
if that would have happened to me and I
was in charge
after I'd made all those mistakes here's
what I would say
I would say the following things and I
made that speech and that speech
was viewed a lot and I did a bunch of
media around it because a bunch of media
Outlets contacted me and want wanted me
to talk about it the the I did a Fox
News segment on it which has
seven million views uh the videos that I
put out had a couple million
all all together
so and then a couple other people what
is it called ripped it and put it on
their own and so it you know probably
got eight to ten million views viral we
and then I'm including this with one of
the two things but then Daryl Cooper and
I did an unraveling podcast where we
went hard and aggressive towards the
situation that made that uh that
unraveling podcast was like the number
one podcast in history for a while it
went right to the Chart so we'll so
between those two things I'm sure I
pissed some people off
and when you piss these people off
they can take action the action that
they can take is suppressing your voice
so what do you think what's your
assessment on that one yeah that's
that's that's kind of scary when you put
it like that when you meanwhile
literally literally that's what it is
and the
kind of for like a better term scary
part of it is I totally forgot about
that yeah I was like Hey Jocko that was
that was a heavy speech and and then you
guys yeah you were super pumped on the
speech too because you sent me a text
and I'm ready to join the SEAL Teams
right now and I'm a 43 year old man I
was like cool yes sir
and then you guys you and Daryl did that
podcast and I remember Daryl saying hey
like there I've been getting a lot of
think can you can you tell me the
numbers I remember seeing the numbers
being like damn okay like dang you guys
kind of must have went hard and you know
I listened to a little bit of it and it
was gone oh I was going moving forward I
forgot about it I I have a lot of
military seal friends of mine were like
send me to dude God yeah hell yeah and
then Special Operations guys hell yeah
and then military everyone was fired up
about that
because we said what needed to be said
and the the Biden the the if I was
president speech people were definitely
fired up about that stuff and so when
you make a mark like that against think
about it think about like think about
that for a second we know the world
knows America American politicians
understand the power of social media
they understand what it means when
something goes viral they understand
those things
and when you have the most you know when
you have the power the seat of power and
you've offended them what do you think
they're gonna do and they also realize
that you can gain momentum they're like
thinking holy [__] you know I bet you
some of those people on the other side
watch that speech and went God damn like
this all right this hurts yeah yeah and
they hear that they go you know what we
need to do what we can to to suppress
this individual's voice and so
I think that very well may have been
the thing that got me
Shadow Band by the way I'm on Shadow
band now by the way we have
Troopers in the game inside these social
media organizations that believe in
Freedom that
now that they're on it I don't think
it's gonna happen again I well let me
not say that we will we we should know
quicker if it happens again we should
see I should find out quicker because we
have people that will report to us if
this happens again yeah that's that's
crazy too when you think about really
the content of what you said obviously
I'm not gonna go through the whole thing
or whatever it wasn't like
I mean I guess at the end of the day you
were kind of taking a position or
whatever but you that wasn't really what
it was about you were just essentially
saying hey this is what I would have
done straight up it's a it's a straight
up hypothetical literally yeah and that
being said yeah and so it does I made
the administration look like idiots
that's what I'm saying it at the end of
the day that's what it was it wasn't
something that's gonna hurt like someone
or cause like a riot or you know there's
a bunch of reasons that I'm legitimate
where you're kind of like hey I
understand why you'd want to kind of at
least like slow that guy down because
even though he's freedom of speech sure
like it could get kind of dangerous if
it kind of goes beyond a certain point
and then think about this think about
this think oh who's this guy and then
they start pulling the thread and they
go wait a second this guy what
motherfucker's listening to him people
are listening to him oh he's written a
bunch of books that are very very
popular oh he has this profile over here
oh but what can we what can we um what
can we burn him on yeah what how can we
call this guy out for being you know uh
whatever conspiracy how can we do that
and then they're looking at my thing
going away it's not going to work what
are we going to make stick to this guy
uh gosh he's got whatever freaking 20
years of military 100 military service
he's got businesses he's got companies
he's got money he's got like he he's
gonna be a hard target yeah what are we
gonna do we know we got to do suppress
him yeah get him suppress him that's
what we're gonna do and that's what they
did
and and they did it for a couple months
but yeah it's because when I went back
in retro I like looked at my uh
followers
there you know I would normally get
followers you know every day yeah yeah
and all of a sudden all of a sudden it's
like oh there oh there was no followers
this day oh there was no followers that
day oh there was no followers that day
and again it's not something I was
looking at but when I went and looked at
it
oh they've put me on lockdown
so it's disturbing
um
that was number one so that that may
have been it but those two things I
guess it's two things but the
combination of those two things one of
them probably caught their attention the
other one said that we we need to
suppress this guy we need to get him
under control
here's the other one and I don't know if
this one might even be scarier
um did another unraveling episode
and this unraveling episode that we did
meet Daryl Cooper we had a guy on there
named Brian suits who's uh he's a
veteran he was in Iraq he was in Bosnia
um and he's he has his own podcast and
he's a
kind of conservative guy
but you know whatever okay cool
um
but I but so we did a podcast about
basically I I opened up this podcast and
when I opened up this podcast talking
about was I was explaining I was talking
about the difference between strategic
thinking and tactical thinking which
you've heard me talk about in all kinds
of podcasts and I talk about all the
time from a leadership perspective
and explaining how strategic is
long-term thinking and tactical is
short-term thinking and with the when
you think strategic that's what you need
to do long term to win and then I
explained that China is thinking
strategic right now
and
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we
you mobilized
Underground